Goodbye Philadelphia and goodbye family.
Hello coffee on a Tuesday in hd.
Well,
so last week,
48 civilian protesters were killed in
Tahrir Square Cairo in Egypt.
Two thousand nine months ago.
The square looked like this.
So what happened?
Maybe you know the story of ancient
Egypt.
Maybe Mr Greg spent three whole weeks on
it in fifth grade and you learned about
Pharaohs and Hieroglyphics and pyramids,
which you later made for a project out
of foam board or cardboard or sugar
cubes or cheats at the very least.
You know
a young man,
he never thought in people's standard
feed the boy
and maybe you thought all that was
fascinated with the story of modern
Egypt is just as incredible and it's so
much at the heart of the cultural shift
happening in the Middle East right now
that we ought to get an idea of how it
goes.
Well,
it goes like this.
The man looks and Egyptian military cask
held power in Egypt from 1250 to 1517
when the Turks,
the Ottoman Empire bitch him out and
took control and he kept it until 1798
when Napoleon bitched them.
And finally in 18,
oh,
one napoleon himself was bitched by the
Brits.
The Brits were only there because the
French war,
so when the French were expelled,
the Brits left to eating a vacuum of
power,
which the Turks and the mamluks jumped
to fill.
In the end,
it was neither work nor Mamluk who seize
control,
but rather an Albanian commander who
played the two against each other called
Mohammed Ali.
No,
not that one or that one.
That one here is the beginning of modern
Egypt.
18 Ali began reforming the country into
a modern state building.
It's military,
it's industry,
and it's educated bureaucracy basically
from scratch it more than any man ever
had for Egypt,
single handedly sparking the Arab
renaissance or the Alda.
He won some battles and gain some
territory and lost some battles and lost
some territory.
He got older,
he got paranoid.
He went crazy and he died.
His son assuming power.
Then he died shortly after his nephew
assumed power and he was killed in his
fourth son.
Then his grandson and his great
grandson,
lesser men.
By the 18 eighties,
Egypt had become completely dependent on
England and France for a healthy economy
and when they tried to break away
England,
sent in its forces and occupied the
country,
state under occupation until after the
first world war.
When the war party led by sod,
so cool.
Ask for independence from Britain,
something they thought they had been
promised for their sacrifice in the war.
They exiled to go to Malta,
and this sparked a grassroots uprising,
the revolution of 1919.
The result of this was the official
independence of Egypt in 1992 and the
drafting of the Constitution a year
later,
but their independence was largely in.
The agent was now a monarchy with a king
backed by the British and subservient to
the British Consulate,
Jim.
He died before World War Two and was
replaced with 16 year old King Farouk.
The.
This guy was a British puppet.
The Brits used Egypt as a base of allied
operations all throughout World War II
propaganda from Germany,
the Soviet Union and the United States
all added to anti British.
Sent them in 1948 Egypt blunder through
the Arab Israeli war,
losing 78 percent of Palestine and the
process the country blamed you guessed
it for the movement called the Free
Officers led by Mohammed the grief and
the mall.
Nasir orchestrated a military coup in
1952,
Egypt's second 20th century revolution.
They overthrew for root tossed away the
1923 constitution and declared Egypt a
Repub,
setting up a one party system made of
all three officers called the liberation
route.
Now Gleam was declared,
the first president of Uja drafted a new
constitution,
a secular in nature,
which a group called the Muslim
Brotherhood apoe.
Two years later,
the Muslim Brotherhood was outlawed as
an illegal political organization.
Two years after that,
and the Gui was replaced with Nasser as
the second president of Egypt,
and his first action was to announce the
nationalization of the Suez Canal is a
manmade canal,
was a trade super highway for the middle
of England and France were pissed
because they use the canal so much that
they hatched a plan with Israel to
overflow.
Naval Base Britain prepares well.
The worst crisis,
it was a secret plan at a stupid plant
and they should have told the US because
when I found out he was pissed,
not consulted in any way about any phase
of these actions.
Wes was like,
get the fuck out of their service.
Prestige was cemented by a proxy victory
of the Suez Canal crisis.
He rolled for another 18 years,
promoted pan Arab Islam all throughout
his term lead the six day war against
Israel,
which he lost embarrassingly and then he
died quietly,
is vice president Anwar Sadat succeeded
him as the third president of Egypt,
so that's most notable accomplishment
was his participation in the camp.
David accords with President Carter and
Prime Minister David Ben Gurion,
which led to the eventual peace treaty
with Israel Treaty,
which is still honored today,
but Sudan and Egypt were ostracized for
this from the Arab League.
Opposition came at them from all sides
and during a military parade on the
sixth of October,
1981 for assassins broke through the
barricades and killed his vice
president.
Hosni Mubarak assume power as the fourth
and last president of Egypt.
Mubarak maintain the peace agreement
with Israel while salvaging Egypt's
relationship with the Arab Lee being
readmitted.
In 1989,
he privatized much of the economy and
Egypt saw extreme growth in the 19
nineties,
partly due to the $14,000,000,000,
had gotten debt relief for participation
in the Gulf War,
but Mubarak was an autocrat like sedans
before him and Nasir before him.
He reigned unchallenged for 26 years and
in the first election that saw a second
candidate in 2005.
That candidate,
Amen.
Our was imprisoned and we can forget
that Egypt has been under emergency law
since 1967,
which is spends constitutional rights
legalize the censorship and extends
police powers under Mubarak.
There were repeated occurrences of
police brutality and severe corruption
among government officials who were
hoarding massive amounts of wealth for
themselves.
By 2011 after a severe worldwide
economic crisis,
the emotion came to a head and we
watched day by day as protestors storm
tower your square and demanded Mubarak
stepped down.
After 29 years
inspired by a popular uprising in
Tunisia,
thousands of Egyptians took to the
streets demanding the alto of president
postnatal.
Oh,
800 years of history.
You can see how Egypt has just a how it
moved from a tribal state to assault in
it to a kingdom to republic.
You can see in Egypt the weight of
Middle Eastern history as it tries to
crash on the shore of freedom and
democracy,
but you can also see that their history
is one of blood and ferment,
lit exclusively by military leaders and
always in flow well,
it's the military who has control,
again,
as the interim leaders,
a Supreme Council of Twenty generals
postpones,
a civilian rule government to the dismay
of many protests begin again.
Dozens have been killed,
the council and apologizes,
but it falls on deaf ears.
Monday saw the start of a long process
of parliamentary elections,
which won't deliver a new president
until mid to late 2012.
In the meantime,
the counsel stays in charge who will
step forward.
The Muslim Brotherhood made legal again
after 57 years and sure to be a big
winner in the first round of
parliamentary election.
Will it be leftists,
revolutionaries,
or just successes and Mu Bar?
Nobody really knows how it's all going
to turn out,
but maybe this is the most important
statistic.
It's how much 40 percent of Egypt makes
per day.
Egyptians want change,
but they need stability and with change
there is no stability and with stability
there is little change.
How do they find democracy and who will
be the stewards of revolution in Egypt
and the movement and the movement called
the three officers led by Muhammad and
the movement and the movement called the
Free Officers led by Mohammad.